hello reject nation it's Greg Alba here
and I'm John it's interesting filming
knowing this will go up on YouTube after
we gave the announcement video that we
are back on YouTube
we watched Jumanji welcome to the jungle
the highly anticipated sequel that we've
been wanting all these years has finally
arrived in the format we've all been
wanting it to be and no one's been upset
and no one's childhood has been ruined
whatsoever with a solid 80 something
percent on Rotten Tomatoes it must be a
good movie right well before we go into
a review we want to give one more thank
you to our friends over at Stardust
Stardust is an awesome app that the real
rejects has partnered up with it's an
app that allows you to do 30-second
reviews for any TV show film or trailer
even and we've been using it a hell of a
lot right now they've been great to us
for almost a twenty three hundred
followers so if you haven't followed us
yet download the app and follow us first
especially because a lot of your
favorite youtubers are also using it as
well and like we promised for our movie
reviews we'll feature some of our
followers reactions here you go hey guys
so I just got out of Jumanji welcome to
the jungle I suppose it's a fun family
adventure not really original sometimes
I just need a little fun one of the
movies Jumanji is a lot of fun enjoyed
it and we had lots of laughs it takes
everything that you knew flips it on its
head there are some problems some of the
CGI's kind of lame and the dialogue of
course gets crazy at times it's
something you can take the whole family
to I think the best part was the dynamic
Jumanji cats apart from Dwayne the rock
Johnson being badass awesome alright
guys download the app and follow us
first now here's our review of Jumanji
okay walking into this movie I wasn't
exactly hyped for it nor was I not
looking forward to this film I feel like
even in the trailers I've been saying in
the reactions that I I don't feel like
my childhoods gonna be ruined I'm not
gonna revisit the first Jumanji before
watching this cuz if anything it might
make me hate this one even more I feel
like I'd be able to just accept what
this film is on its own merits if I
don't have the original one really fresh
in my mind going into this film with
that clean slate I walked out just going
it's alright it's okay I don't love it I
don't hate it it's the definition of
just an OK film to me that's fun it's a
good time at the theaters on a Friday
night or something like that this is the
first movie in a while where I saw the
trailer and the movie was exactly what I
expected it to be
I thought almost nothing was more or
less than I thought it was gonna be I
thought it was less fun than I
anticipated it to be to be honest you
know it's technically fun the same time
though all I wanted out of it was okay I
don't need this to be better than the
first Jumanji when I saw that it stars
the rock and Kevin Hart and Jack Black
all three who I think are great in
comedies and often have had films where
I am dying of laughter from some of
their jokes this film never had them in
a single moment for me where I was like
like I just cracked up at something one
of them said or did and that was a
missing element for me was honestly the
comedy just wasn't that strong to me
there's moments where I Chuck old
there's moments where I kind of laugh
there was never really that that one
moment just even one were like wow that
was a hilarious yeah and I feel like
when you got those stars in this movie
you should have at least one of those
moments at least one I see how it guides
your expectations casting 2 mega comedy
stars in a movie like this but I never
expected it to be a flat-out comedy I've
selected there to be a good amount of
banter based humor and a lot of
action-adventure I felt like the comedy
would be present but not focal force of
the of the movie you know I don't know I
felt like it would be an action
adventure comedy i didn't think it would
need to be like jokes every few minutes
because I feel like the adventure needs
to continue at a clip I feel like as the
comedy was going I think they did a lot
of repetition with the jokes a lot of
callbacks and there are some jokes that
they just kept repeating that I didn't
even find funny the first time they said
it and it doesn't become funnier the
more they say it just kind of becomes
annoying they come out and tell you
things that you remember it doesn't
always give you the credit for
remembering who the characters are and
why this joke is funny so they'll
directly address certain things and yeah
it does stall the comedic antem a little
bit like a couple of examples I can give
you as the joke of how Jack Black
originally which is not in the video
game it's a girl and now Jack likes an
overweight middle-aged man she really
wants her phone the whole time wait a
second where's my phone and it's like
that joke just kept getting beeped to
the ground and another one - is Kevin
Hart's characters a zoologist guy who
knows a lot about animals so when he's
in the game he's gonna know a lot of
facts about animals and everytime he
spits out a bunch of facts about animals
it's always followed up with the same
joke which is the same thing over again
get used to it and then you would know
how yeah and the adventure moments are
fun it's a video game is enjoyable it is
a very linear it's almost like after
earth where it's just like okay now we
got to go do this and now we go do that
and then we're gonna you know do the
next task
yeah next oh yeah yeah and in a lot of
ways I respected that I actually like
the format of how they each have three
lives they can die three times before
their life is actually over before it's
game over and I like the riffs it makes
on how video games work and they make
fun of cutscenes when they make fun of
how you encounter characters you just
repeat the same exact line a dialogue
over and over again the feeling of I
feel like I'm watching a movie that's
bigger than it's actually making me feel
like it's this big adventure this land
of awe and jungles and whatever but then
when I'm watching it I'm not really
feeling all that excited about it it's
it's really just an OK experience it's
really like yeah that's that's something
to pass the time right there where
despite what you might think of the
first Jumanji I feel like there is a
sense of wonder and awe and I haven't
seen a movie in many years but I
remember
that feeling pretty well there's a magic
about it yeah this doesn't have any of
that this is more focused on being a a
modern straightforward you know
action-adventure comedy if heels more
like a movie whereas Jumanji kind of
felt like a film you know with its own
earmarks and its own trades I mean this
for me was just brisk and amusing and
enjoyable and fun and it never bored I
never got bored and there was spent -
and never spent that much time on
hormones - anything partly I kind of was
happy it wasn't like hey comedy I was
like oh cool it's kind of more on an
adventure it's taking the adventure
elements more seriously because I
thought some of the action was actually
intense and some of the action was
actually shocked pretty well that whole
first sequence where they got the all
those motorcycles and they're like
trying to evade and stuff like that like
yeah after the disasters in the
helicopter scene a couple of the felt
like the hand-to-hand fights aren't
tremendous but you know there's some
moments where those even got to be fun
where they're showing how crazy strong
the rock is and I thought they got a lot
of mileage out of that stuff because
usually for you know I don't know how
Jake Kasdan would have directed action
and I was surprised that it looked
better than I thought it would that's
important for a movie like this one that
is also ramping up the action
specifically because the original g-man
Jumanji isn't like a fighting action
movie or a guns action adventure you
know it's an adventure yeah so the
action part I thought they handled
pretty well I guess I mean I feel like
there's a couple of moments or scenes
that I thought were kind of cool I
really just felt like I was
intermittently feeling like I was
entertained the rocks good in it Kevin
Hart is good in it Jack Black and Karen
Gillan they're all good and I am one
person who surprised me that I was like
hey I really like him in this was Nick
Jonas Nick Jonas ends up being the
character I actually cared the most
about he's the only one where I actually
felt stakes everyone else I'm like that
whatever but Nick Jonas is character he
comes in lady to the film but when he
comes in you learn about who he is he's
the one who I felt like I'm concerned I
hope he survives this mission he's the
only one I felt that way about I've kind
of heard that he's a pretty alright
actor and yeah I liked him in this I
didn't like loved him considerably more
than anybody else really has to do yeah
I kind of felt on the same level about
everybody I thought the ensemble in
general had a nice chemistry I thought
everybody
had their moments I thought they've
brought a lot of good character to it
even if they didn't all match their
teenage counterparts Jack Black matches
his the most that was also an issue I
had with the film was why is only Jack
Black the one who's trying to actually
match his teenage counterpart Kevin Hart
and the rock they're just kind of doing
their own thing and doing them whereas
Jack Black has a lisp and mannerisms and
is doing things that embody the teenage
version well I mean your posture and the
way you speak are gonna carry over into
whatever body or you like your brain is
still the same and that's really brain
that's my point is Kevin Hart and Dwayne
Johnson don't do that Karen Gillan I
thought kind of does because she affects
the more like awkward like she does
physical things to clue you into like oh
yeah okay I kind of get that you're not
who you look like
and I thought the rock did too I thought
he did the shy it's just that none of
them are as a big a character as a
valley girl obsessed with her phone is
it's like nerd guy jock guy intelligent
very pretty but somehow were pretending
you're not pretty girl and then valley
girl and so like she's the biggest of
all those characters to me even in the
beginning cuz she's doing the most
outlandish stuff in the prologue to
she's on her phone in the millah
has like an understandable thing that
winds them in trouble and gets him in
this whole situation
and the first place except for her she's
like the most outlandish of the three of
them no I get it I do I do I'm not
saying what Jack Locke did was wrong I
thought it was distracting though that
he was the only one because he came is
like his favorite cuz Kevin Hart and
know a lot of people are actually saying
that I was distracted by it because
Kevin Hart speech pattern or rhythm is
like jacket like other changes his you
know he has the Lisp he has the delivery
that's all like a valley girl whereas
Kevin Hart is coming from a character
who's an athletic jock from high school
and has a very specific way of coming
across
none of that translates into Kevin
Hart's performance the rocketship is
doing the nervous that he's doing that
things on paper that he's supposed to do
but none of it reminds me of the teenage
version the only one that remind me of
the teenager was Jack Black so it kind
of has both factors one is that's why
Jack Black's the best and another part
is that's why I was kind of distracted
by Jack okay yeah because the other
actors were
doing in as strongly as Jack Black was
the only like issue I had with this
movie overall and it's not really that
big of an issue because you know the
movies not concerned with being overly
dramatic but like Bobby kind of Olly is
in here is ostensibly the villain and I
feel like we're doing a lot of these
adventure or you know sci-fi action
movies were like we're just forgetting
about the villain as a character and I
thought like the design and the idea of
him was cool but I'm like you got Bobby
Cannavale a and he pops up every couple
minutes yeah that could have used like a
stronger villain of some kind to make
the riding or Bobby just the writing of
that character I thought he did a fine
job like at the end I was like I was
halfway on that character the whole time
I was like I'm intrigued and we're
wrapping up yeah he's a character with a
cool power a really strong power yet
it's not it's not really utilized to the
strengths that it could have been yeah I
just felt like this one was lacking in a
lot of areas to be honey it's to feel
like if you amped up the villain and
amped up his and really utilize the
powers they establish for him that would
have made the whole adventure a lot more
interesting I mean I don't think this
movie is necessary to do a spoiler talk
on but I also say that there were some
reveals by the end of this movie the way
they tie it into the original Jumanji
that actually made the universe of
Jumanji actually make less sense based
off of certain maybe I'll do some reply
to someone or something one day there
were things about the way it all
concludes in the end where I'm like wait
a minute but the way it plays out for
Robin Williams character in the
beginning of Jummah no this doesn't make
sense but other than that if all you
really cared about was just an enjoyable
film that has moments of excitement in
it and some amusing comedy it's the mark
pretty much I think a little bit less
than I would have liked but overall yeah
I think it's alright yeah it's not
dynamite but it's it's well-made enough
it's straightforward enough the the cast
is all pretty good the adventure is fun
it's I don't think it's gonna stick with
anybody the way the first one did but
it's definitely a fun time at the
theater yeah you know it did some things
more than I thought in some things less
than I thought so I kind of come out in
a pleasant middle ground alright guys
well did you see Jumanji welcome to the
jungle did it ruin your childhood
comment below you can subscribe to the
real rejects please click that
notification
station bell you can follow us on social
media download and follow us at the
Stardust at people and become a patron
object today over at patreon it's become
our second YouTube channel a lot of fun
exclusive perks over there exclusive
video content and specialty
check it out